now dealing with a severe terrorist
threat which means an attack is highly
likely right across Northern Ireland I
think the thing to stress for members
and Beyond Today is that main focus of
these attacks can continues to be police
officers both on and off duty as you say
and their families it will also include
prison officers and military personnel
and the style of attack that we're
dealing with and trying to frustrate is
gun attack and bomb attacks on these
people by a small number of determined
dissident terrorists
what this means is that working with our
security Partners there's an assessment
about an increase in their intent and
capability to cause serious harm to us
in the next six months